[Music]
current tensions between South Korea and
North Korea are higher than they've been
in years these hostilities continued for
a simple reason the Korean War never
ended when combat stopped in 1953 no
peace treaty was ever signed just a
ceasefire which continues to this day
leaving the two countries separated by
the DMZ or demilitarized zone filled
with high-voltage fence and over 1
million landmines and a long-ass
no-man's land there is just one point
where these enemies can stand
face-to-face be JSA or joint security
area here the border between North and
South Korea runs along a concrete curb
and bisects blue conference rooms where
the two sides have occasionally met for
diplomatic talks the JSA has more often
been the site of hundreds of acts of
violence and provocations given this
situation I could think of no two better
people to visit the JSA than Conan
O'Brien and Steven Yeun well we are in
the DMZ this is surreal that is North
Korea right there those are North
Koreans staring back at us he's probably
freaking out because he recognizes both
of us he's a huge walking dead and team
cocoa fan that's Bob we named him Bob
they do 12-hour shifts does the guy
change where the name stays the same
yeah we don't know their names
tell them Bob that guy is shoveling
shoveling shoveling lies I say you're
the best-dressed soldier I've ever seen
in my life yeah look at Janet Jackson a
backup dancer
is little to me and the explain what's
happening there now in the room and
we've been told that when we cross past
this table we will be in North Korea why
does this historically significant
building that links these two separated
countries look so much like the business
centre of a Ramada Inn sir you do
realize that you're wearing sunglasses
indoors in a snowstorm what the other
people are doing as well okay I guess if
I jumped off a bridge you would as well
sorry this is probably not the time or
the place for my quips you're in North
Korea I'm in North Korea Forrest I'm
still in South Korea
I hope congratulations North Korea and
is this gentleman with us what are you
talking about so I will not touch this
man and do not go behind it this is
crazy so we've just been told not to
touch this man or go behind him which is
usually my rule with any man all right
we're here we are in North Korea will be
you
I mean working digits in the wash
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and I guess Steven Yeun from Walking
Dead
so how's your life going it's going it's
going pretty good
I'm getting married you're getting
married yes that's fantastic
did you hear that he's getting married
so you excited about the new season of
Walking Dead it's um you worked really
hard on it I'm told you have a clip yes
does North Korea know that we're here
right now Sony North Korean officials
are watching us right now two minutes
okay
we've been obviously kidding around a
little bit yeah but this is a serious
thing the idea that you and I could be
in North Korea talking and communicating
freely seems like kind of a cool message
honestly I never would have ever thought
I could do this this is the dream Yance
the dream is to unify yeah the dream is
to bring families and people together
and that's the hope right it's it's so
surreal that this separation is
completely man-made and ridiculous so
let's hope that changes
[Music]
hey this is Conan O'Brien I'm reporting
from North Korea with the weather it is
cloudy overcast light snow showers about
28 degrees here now with the weather
from South Korea Stephen you and Stephen
hey thank you Conan South Korea with the
weather report it's the same we're gonna
throw a commercial now this whole
segment has been sponsored by indoor
sunglasses everyone in the DMZ
[Applause]
you